Welcome friends. Whether you're out on a
walk,
running errands, or relaxing at home,
it's wonderful to connect with you.
Joining us today is Dennis Barros.
Dennis is the author of Wired Like This:
Why Men Push Too Far and Still Say,
I Got It! He's a husband, a father of
three,
with a background in senior leadership.
He writes.
about the small everyday decisions at
home,
at work, on the sideline of a kid's game
that shape
how men actually behave.
Dennis, welcome to Phoenix in Flame.
Yeah, thanks for having me. Guilty.
Yeah, all all is all is correct on there.
I did write that
Ha ha
book. Yeah, happy to be here and yeah,
looking forward to the conversation.
This is fantastic. So what first of all
I'm interested
in a bit of your background. Like you said
you were in senior leadership,
~ since I do a lot of work with with
corporate space and and helping people
with
burnout. That was one of the things that
drew me to you is is the
the mindset that what you're presenting as
the the masculine,
the male mindset that could possibly trip
somebody up.
~ at work, because I I I work with high
performers and they're saying
the things that you have in your book.
So I'm interested just kind of I'm
creating some space for you
to share what experiences have you had in,
you know, senior leadership? What have you
noticed there?
And also with your family ~ and
Sure.
how these things have helped you arrive at
writing a book.
Yeah, so I've I've been in the fitness
industry for for quite some time.
It's practically been my entire career.
And most of the organizations I've been
with,
including the current one now,
have been really high volume, high growth
type of companies.
so I currently oversee over twenty-nine
locations here in Texas.
~ fitness big box fitness use spaces and ~
so really rampant growth.
And so most of my career, like I
mentioned.
~ I've I've had to move pretty fast.
it's just nonstop. I've had to work a lot,
you know, and and most of it is is
self-induced,
you know, just me trying to keep up and
trying to be a high performer myself.
And ~ so I think that's carried,
I think that's natural for me.
I'm a natural leader, and so I'm always
taking,
you know, probably more ownership than the
average person.
And so ~ that's been instilled in me,
you know, with my family and my children.
I noticed early on that I brought that
over to my kids as well.
You know, once my kids started getting
into youth sports,
~ that kind of drive, that push,
the, you know, the long practices,
the long hours. You know, it's funny,
I on a podcast, I was last week,
I was asked, you know, hey, do do you feel
like you bring over your competitiveness
prior, you know, maybe from your past as a
child competing in sports?
Have you brought that over to your kids?
And I I thought to myself for a second,
I
You know, I don't think so. ~ I don't have
like this unsettled,
you know, failed athletic career or
something that I'm trying to settle with
my children. But I think it's just natural
for me to push and to teach kids and to,
hey, if you if you want to get better at
something,
you gotta keep practicing, you gotta keep
moving.
So yeah, I'm kind of an all or nothing
person.
~
I don't watch many sports, but the sports
that I do I'm all in,
like all are all in die hard fan.
And so that's that's really how I run my
life and it's it's you know very much
natural for
~ I I love this description that you're
giving.
And I as I'm as I'm thinking, you'll
notice as I look down,
I'm I'm taking notes as as you're talking
because I don't want to interrupt you.
But I I would like to be able to say the
same thing.
no, I I'm I'm a very competitive I get
bruises playing musical chairs.
And I'm not that's
Ha ha ha.
that's not hyperbole. I literally have
bruises from my shoulders
to my ankles playing musical chairs one
year at a fall festival at my church.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
So I'm thinking of the phrase,
if you're not bleeding, you're not
playing.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
I mean, I have three kids as well,
and and my husband is also a very
competitive person.
And so that's like if it they would say
that,
you know, if you're not bleeding,
you're not playing. ~
Mm-hmm.
and I my youngest son ~ confronted me
appropriately so one time.
Because I said to him one too many times,
stop half assing it.
Yeah.
And he he like kind of link to me.
And I feel like it was appropriate because
I was so in my own head about push,
push, push, push, push. And
Mm-hmm.
he'd had it, and I'd gone too far.
And I think that's a lot of what you're
talking about in your book that
I want to hear much more about.
And as we kind of segue into that,
your book is focused on men.
And I also want to bring up,
If you feel like, if your experience has
been,
not necessarily with your daughter,
but with other coworkers, with friends,
do you feel like it it can be a
personality style?
Cause ~ have you run into men that did not
have this this kind of,
I got it, I'm I'm I'm you know,
I'm gonna push this, I'm not gonna use
GPS,
I'm gonna figure this out.
How much of that do you feel like is a is
a male trait,
which I feel like a lot of people would
agree with,
and have you seen these traits also in
some women that you've interacted with
along
your lifetime?
Certainly, you know, what I can share,
you know, from a I guess from a female
perspective,
you know, my wife and I, the dynamic
between us,
I mean, my wife works incredibly hard,
she works remote, she homeschools all
three of our children now,
she works out every day, ~ but she's got
this like self-regulation
in her that I don't seem to have.
Or at least mine doesn't work.
Like she she
She will come up with reasons to sleep and
the needs for sleeping.
And I come up with reasons not to sleep.
Even though I I have a
Stay.
fitness-minded background, I know the
importance of it,
but for whatever reason, I can't seem to
sleep past whatever 6 a.m.
on a Saturday. You know, so ~ so I see
similarities across the board.
you know, what's interesting is when I
release the book.
I started getting people who would call or
text or I run into them.
And people, men who I think we have such
different personalities,
like completely different. ~ I've run into
guys that don't have children,
they don't participate in sports,
they're not ultra competitive.
And they read my book and started telling
me,
hey, we're a lot alike.
Mm.
And I found that interesting. And so I
think that ~ you know.
There are so many patterns and
similarities between whatever it may be,
male or female, but obvious obviously I'm
focusing on the male perspective because
that's
Sure.
that's who I'm mostly around. And I think
that at the surface it may look
a little bit different, but deep down,
you know, there's some drives in people
that are very similar.
I got that. I got that. You pointed out
something in your book that
I thought was really interesting,
especially when with my exposure to high
performers,
because I've had them in my office on
FMLA,
~ having panic attacks and they just they
they push,
push, push, push, and they don't know how
to I'm I'm known as
the Queen of Boundaries and so I've they
didn't have They didn't know how
to set the boundaries and they were just
pushing and pushing.
You had something in your book that I
thought was interesting that I wanted
you to maybe take some time and expound
on.
Is this whole
this idea, this feeling that if you don't,
if you if you go slow, then you're gonna
lose out.
Mm-hmm.
If you don't pick up the pace,
if you're not the first one there,
~ if you're not the first one to figure it
out,
if you're not the first one in the in the
office,
if you're not the first one with the
answer,
if if you slow down, if you bring
Mm-hmm.
it down from eighty five miles an hour
down to fifty five,
you're simply gonna lose out. Someone else
is gonna get it in front of you,
which I think is
Sure.
such a common experience.
Tell us more about your experience with
that,
people that you've seen, and and what's in
your book about that.
Yeah, I I I can offer two perspectives.
So one is, you know, I as I grew up,
I think work ethic was or still is really
a ~ I look at it as
a is my main skill, right? I think that
you know for for people like me,
we believe that if you work harder than
most people,
you're gonna be much further ahead than
most.
And I and I think that can be true in many
cases.
And so I think that carries on naturally
for me.
~ the other side of it is ~ the ego and
the pride.
You know, I think that still exists in so
many pieces of business and in leadership.
~ is that if you put in longer hours,
~ you know, it's interesting when we when
I travel a lot for work and
we do grand openings and open up new
locations,
and you know, there's a lot of executive
leadership there and you know,
peers of mine, and there's almost this
like ~
There's almost this like competition of
like who's gonna leave first or stay
later.
And like, you know, and it's it's it's and
it's so it's
so silly at but it's it drives people like
who's gonna be the first leave,
who's gonna be last to leave, who's
putting in longer hours.
~ you know, so I I think that exists and I
think subconsciously it
it it fuels exactly what we do in some
cases.
And so ~ that's what I would offer is
You know, I think work ethic is still a
main skill and still a trait that
I think does carry most people further
than others.
~ and then if you know, I think there's a
lot of ~ talk and there's
a lot of opinions being thrown out about
younger generations and how
you know their work ethic is lesser or
whatnot.
And so I think even more so it's amplified
now that we're trying
to show younger generations that you do
need to put in work.
And so, but
You gotta find the balance, right?
And and and avoid,
Mm-hmm.
you know, the the hot the hot word
burnout.
So
Yeah. That's a big deal. I love the word
that you use balance,
because that's that's it, right?
In a you know, in a big way. It's sort of
like if you go too far with a push,
push, push, push, push, then you are gonna
burn out if you add too many things.
But on the other hand, there's the other
end of that spectrum where
if you don't have some kind of work ethic,
then yes, if
You know, other people are going to
perform better than you and they
are going to get the raises. They are
going to get the promotions.
And that's just that's how life works.
But it's trying
Mm-hmm.
to find that balance. ~ you you had
mentioned something in your book about
the cold plunge. And I love this,
I love this example, and I would like to
hear you talk about how we sometimes will
add things like that, thinking,
this is this is going to give me the edge.
This is a good idea. Right. And there's
always another good idea around the
corner.
The thing of it is, in my mind,
I w I'm I'm interested in your thoughts
about the short game versus
the long game because in it
The wheel.
looking at it in terms of burnout,
how many things can we add that we might
look fantastic in the short game,
but
We're not gonna last long doing all
Sure.
of that.
And I just kinda wondered what your
experience was and your thoughts
and and talking about your the cold plunge
and cracking that ice outside.
Well,
I'll give I'll give you a great I'll give
you a great example.
I do I do write about this. So I I
consider myself
not a professional multitasker,
but a certainly a someone who just lives
on that most
of my just most of my days and most of my
weeks.
I mean, I'm and I I'm conscious about it.
I'm like, hey, Dennis, you're doing too
much.
You should stop. But it's just I'm wired
like that,
where I have to.
Find all of the different opportunities to
use up my time.
And so not long ago, I was traveling for
work.
I was heading to ~ to one city and was
only going there for an interview
and then heading right back to the airport
and going to another city.
And I was gonna be there for a couple of
days.
And so I'm in the rental car driving to
the airport,
and I thought I got about 20 or 25
minutes.
I needed to make a couple of calls.
And so for me, if I'm in work mode,
there's no podcast, there's no music,
I'm just trying to find every single thing
that I can do in in
it throughout the day. So I take two
calls,
I'm on, I'm in the rental car,
I pull up to the airport, ~ disconnect the
Bluetooth,
put my headphones in, wave the woman off,
start walking to the terminal.
Get to TSA, grab my briefcase,
put it in, and I'm like, shit,
where's my carry-on? So left it in the
car.
I'm walking back, finally finished my
phone call,
of course. Called the wife, let her know.
I said, Hey, I left my carry on,
just just a heads up. And she's like,
Are you gonna make it? And like,
without a doubt, I'm like, Yeah,
I'm gonna make it. It's only like a
five-minute walk.
So I get back and the car is gone,
nowhere to be found. I'm sitting there
waiting,
waiting, waiting. And so to me,
like
And and that's a mistake that I often make
and I will reflect on it,
but it's it's sometimes hard to peel back.
So the you know, just the multitasking and
then trying to cram everything into every
minute and it it costs me because I miss
my flight.
my gosh. That is such a useful and
practical example.
I'm sure listeners right now or viewers on
YouTube are going,
yeah, that's I've done that. I know what
that's like.
It's just sort of like doing spinning so
many plates and you just they just,
you know, they start dropping.
So you write that
I got it might be the most dangerous thing
that men say.
I got it.
I got it. Talk about that. What do you
mean by that?
Why do you feel like that could be the
most dangerous thing that men say?
So I've seen it in a couple of different
ways as well.
And interestingly enough, I've actually
had somebody come to me after reading
about
my book and thinking that the I got it
phrase was actually something different
than
I intended it to be, but I'll expand on
that.
So I think there's certainly a lot of ego
that plays into it
and there's this sense of, you know,
~
security for others and you know for
example like my my wife has since
we moved to north texas she's become like
this expert storm tracker I
I'm not even kidding. I mean the minute we
got off the plane
and our first thunderstorm she she follows
all of the experts
and she it's funny because she knows way
more about storms than I do
now but yet she's still much more bothered
by it.
I ignore all of it. I mean
If it's gonna rain, it's gonna rain,
like we'll deal with it. Right.
And so
Yeah.
I very much am naturally just being the
person that says it's you know,
we'll deal with it when we get to it,
and it's not a big deal, like we'll be
okay.
And sometimes I say that, but I I'm not
even saying that consciously.
I'm just it's just a habit for me to
repeat that back.
And ~ you know, same thing with even just
You know, with me traveling a lot,
I I read about that in the book a lot
where I think,
hey, I'll I'll make my flight.
You know, when I get there, I get there.
Like it's it's no big deal. So I say that
naturally.
I think it hurts me, ~ sometimes for sure.
But the other side of it and the
perspective that I mentioned with with
somebody,
~ is more I think more of like this growth
mindset ~ miss for them is,
you know, I think people get ~
Especially in the leadership world where
you have to put out that you have
all the answers, you have all the
solutions.
And so
Mm-hmm.
I I hear a lot of guys say, I got it,
meaning I understand, I I understand the
objective,
I understand what I need to do,
and it's really not happening.
I think they're just saying that.
I think it's sugarcoating exactly what's
happening,
and they're not afra they're afraid to
say,
Hey, I don't actually have it.
I I need
More clarity on this. I need to learn more
about this.
So I think it can kind of hit in a couple
of different ways.
And I'm seeing that in leadership a lot as
well in the second.
That makes a lot of sense. And I've seen
this as well.
And I've heard people talk about this.
This what I'm hearing you say,
this fear of admitting
Mm.
that they don't know how to do something.
Because if they admit that fear,
then that's, you know, that's failure and
they might be passed over for a promotion.
Someone else might get ahead of them.
I'm
Mm-hmm.
kind of wondering as we're talking about
this,
if you have any insight or wisdom on how
we could create
an environment in the workplace that would
allow people,
would allow men to admit,
you know, look, I I've got this part,
I've got this part on lock, but you know,
I have I don't know really much about this
part over here.
Can can can we team up? Can you help me?
What what are your thoughts on how to
potentially what are some phrases,
some words, some an atmosphere that could
be created that would help to move that
in a better direction?
Yeah, what I try to do, especially as a
leader and also as a as a father
for my children, is explain that,
hey, I expect you to be as resourceful as
you can.
I admire, and you're gonna get a lot of
credit for being the person that just
figures things out, right? And doesn't
always have to ask for help
and just figures things out. You're you're
gonna be more successful than
the average person if you just do that.
However,
When you get to the point where you can't
figure it out anymore,
you've ex you've explored all the
resources,
you have to be able to just pause for a
second and think,
who else can I reach out to? What kind of
an expert can I go to?
Like that is the next level. And I think
framing it that way for people that
you will be more successful, you will be ~
looked at as someone that's admired a
little bit more because you took that
extra
step and you showed courage to ask for
help.
And I so I I think framing it in that way
has helped others in my field of business,
especially for my children as well.
I love this example and I'm thinking about
how teams work and looking
at from a psychological perspective and
that could even offer an opportunity
to lift up a teammate and help them to
Yeah.
feel like they have information that you
need.
They can feel more involved. They can feel
like they have an asset,
something to contribute, because you're
you're going to them and saying,
Hey, I feel like you're an expert in this
area.
I'm not an expert in this area.
Can we
Can we have coffee for like twenty minutes
and let me just pick your brain?
And then that seems like that would would
likely really help
the whole team environment, everyone to
feel a little more appreciated
and acknowledged for what they do know.
Sure. Yeah. You know, I I I I I use the
term level up a lot,
right? And, you know, being a difference
maker.
And so framing it that way, like,
hey, most people, they're gonna do what
you're doing.
They're going to figure it all out.
They're gonna do all the research they
can,
but once they get to that point where they
can't do it anymore,
that's where the next level up happens.
That's where changes really start to
happen.
And also just explaining that.
The pride that's sitting in the way where
you're thinking,
~ well, if I go to this person for some
guidance or help,
they're gonna think of me as lesser and
weak or whatever it is.
Trust me, they're gonna be they're gonna
be thinking more about themselves and how
Yes. ~ yes.
good they feel that you went to them.
Right.
And so I think that's just a mindset
change or shift.
~ that's been a key unlock, I think,
in in many times in my career.
Mm-hmm. That and as you're explaining
this,
I'm thinking about the word that you used
earlier,
balance. And I'm thinking about different
personality styles on teams at work.
And you have on the one end, you would
have,
like you mentioned, someone who has a
whole lot of pride and they're afraid
to admit they don't know the answer to
something.
Well, after a while, you can't trust that
person because you know they're gonna
go too far. You know they're gonna say,
I got it, when they effing don't.
And you're and you're wondering when
that's gonna play out in front of
a client or something like that.
And and so you can't trust that person.
That's too far one direction. And then you
also have people on the other
end of the spectrum that won't ever take
initiative for anything,
maybe because they don't have a lot of
confidence in themselves
or different reasons and they're always
going,
How do I do this? How do I do this?
And they're just very dependent on those
around them.
They won't take that initiative,
they won't try to find the answer.
~ that's the whole other end of the
spectrum that doesn't work well either.
So I I love the the balance that you're
talking about.
~
Yeah.
now your wife in your book, she's a
recurring voice that you bring up.
what do you think she saw in you that you
could not see?
Well, you know, it's interesting.
She she often calls me like a unicorn and
sh it when I came up with the idea
for the book, she's like saying Dennis,
this is not gonna hit home with anyone.
You're you you are unique. I don't I don't
know anyone like you.
But I I was able to convince her otherwise
because I've gotten so many people who've
responded saying, I'm just like you and I
I do the same things,
it's just maybe a little bit different or
whatever.
And so I but she she only sees what she
sees.
And so I think the biggest part for for me
that I got from her
was all around centered around kind of the
youth coaching piece.
She was able to bring
to light that I like visibly appeared more
bothered coaching my kids than other
coaches.
Like I would, we would.
Get in the car and she's like,
Are you okay? You were just, I could just
tell you were pacing,
you're getting louder than you normally
do.
Like, you gotta just chill. And so I would
brush it off at first,
and ~ but it it kind of continued and it
kind of snowballed into some other stories
there. But I I'm so passionate about
coaching and leading and sports
in general and bettering and developing
children.
And so
I would have just kept going in that
direction.
Like to me, it was normal. To me,
it was I see an opportunity to coach a
child,
I do it. You know, I see an opportunity to
address a referee,
I do it. And so to me, it's like that's
that's what I'm supposed to do.
I signed up as head coach, like that's my
job.
~ she was able to frame it in a different
way for me to say,
hey, look, you it's a little you're acting
a little bit different than other
coaches. And so that was probably
the most impactful for my life,
of course, with with parenting is sh she
was able to kind of offer that lens.
Yeah.
Well, when she was making that
observation,
what do you think she was actually
observing?
'Cause you said she said you act a little
different different from other coaches,
you seem more bothered. What what do you f
now that you could have some
you know hindsight, they say, you know,
twenty twenty hindsight, what do you think
was going on with you that
was causing these behavioral changes that
she noticed?
Well, you know, starting off with,
you know, let's say, for example,
T ball, you know, five, six year olds,
maybe a little bit younger. I I noticed
that most coaches were
very hands-off. ~ like I'm talking about
they it was just high fives.
It was you're doing a great job.
Like there was very, very little direction
given,
which is fine. ~ but I started to notice
Children that would sign up for T ball or
whatnot,
or they would give it a year and they just
wouldn't return the next year.
~ because very quickly in baseball and
other sports,
children start to get exposed.
You know, they they get a they're a step
behind other kids,
then it's not fun anymore for them because
they're not playing well,
they're being embar they're getting
embarrassed.
And
I I spent a lot of time with my kids
playing in our backyard and I I would just
put in that extra work with them and I saw
the difference and I started
to have parents come up to me and say
things like,
how often does your parent practice does
your child practice?
they seem to be a natural at it.
And I would get offended. And I would say,
My my child's not a natural. Like I I know
where where he started.
I put in the extra work with him.
And so I saw the difference between a
child who just goes home
and doesn't practice their game and they
just show up for practice once a week.
So my first year of coaching that carried
with me.
And so I just continued to be ~ that coach
that would provide more development,
more direction, constant feedback.
~ but then it started to get it started to
go overboard a little
bit where raising my voice, ~ not
necessarily at the kids.
You know, maybe sometimes directed just at
the environment or the coaches
and things like that. And so I think I saw
a win for me.
I saw it work for my child. And then
naturally it just progressed.
~ and and that's when she started to
notice,
like, hey, I think you're going a little
bit overboard.
Got you. That makes sense. I c I totally
understand that.
So to that point, and I'm thinking about
coaching is a hobby,
or there might be some other hobbies that
that men are involved in.
So what do you think is actually going on
when a guy goes all in on some hobby?
Mm-hmm.
And we all know we all know our our
partners,
our husbands, you know, whoever the guys
that are going all in on some hobby
for maybe even a few years.
Right. They're all in. They're doing all
the things,
buying all the stuff, they're looking it
up online,
all the things. And then they just drop
it.
They just all of a sudden they just drop
What and and here they have all this
equipment,
they've allocated all this time,
all this stuff. So you got a garage full
of all this stuff.
What
Yeah.
what's going on at that point when when
you see a man doing that?
What's what do you see is is happening
there?
For me, it starts as the reason I think we
go all in is it becomes an identity.
It just becomes this is who we want to be.
you know, I I think it's a way to stay
competitive.
I think it's a way to latch on to
something.
Again, it's a it's an identity.
And I think once you realize again,
for me, once I realize that this isn't the
identity that I want anymore
or it's not working.
then you completely drop it. It's almost
like you want to forget that
it ever happened and you latch onto
something else.
And so there's some competitiveness to it.
I think there's some drive, like you you
you start a new hobby and you
you you see where you can get to it and
and or you know,
so I think there's a little bit of that,
but for most I think for most it's it's an
identity thing.
Like I want to be the golfer or I want to
be the car guy or whatever it may be.
I think that's mostly where it comes from.
Yeah. So then why did they just
automatically stop?
It it what happened to that need to I to
identify with that?
Again, for me, it's it's you realize it's
either not working,
it just becomes something that maybe you
failed at.
I never got to the level that I I wanted
to be.
Like, for example, with my son with golf,
I I beg I started to golf myself,
and my son naturally picked it up.
And as soon as I realized I think that
this isn't going to be something that
I'm gonna do for probably a long time,
or I'm not gonna get to the level that I
really would have.
like to be at the beginning and now my
son's into it.
So now it automatic automatically changes.
Now it's now it's my son. So I think it's
a little bit of giving up,
right? And and realizing this isn't going
to be something that I'm going
to be amazing at. And so why don't I just
cut ties with it now?
So that's what I found it to be for me.
~ a little bit is you just kind of lose
that it loses its lust a little bit.
It's it wasn't as sexy as it was in the
beginning.
And
~ you
Wasn't as it's not as novel now.
know, maybe yeah,
maybe also it reminders from the wife that
you're spending too much money
on something also helps and you know
you've gone overboard with that.
So ~ you know, I I think for me it's it's
mostly
~ I I'm not getting to where I initially
thought I would get to.
And so why don't I cut ties?
Mm.
Well I can totally understand that.
And there's there's again back to balance,
I could see how in some instances that
makes total sense.
And then in other ways, if somebody had a
habit of doing this over
and over like they had an expectation of
themselves as being a plus on something,
Sure.
the whole perfectionism thing.
And if they're not a plus, that it won't
have anything to do with it.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Well, and then there's also
the ~ this goes back to,
you know, kind of my obsessive personality
and nature where I I want to
be an expert at whatever hobby that I
have.
~ and so I I mentioned in the book that I
was like this wannabe wine connoisseur
at one point and pairing meals and all
these things,
and then fast forward a couple of years,
I don't even drink it, you know,
but at at the time
Ha ha ha
It was something that I was really excited
about and passionate about.
So I wanted to learn everything about it.
So I think that initial burst of energy
that goes into learning something
new that continues to carry on and that
creates the habit or
the obsession or whatever it is.
~ so yeah, I don't know if that's it's
like that for most,
but for me for sure, it's that initial
burst of energy that I
put into something also triggers that all
in approach.
So as you're explaining that, I I I have a
an observation and a question.
So th the the behavior pattern that you're
describing of being drawn
to something novel, wanting to learn
something new,
that's very common for people that have
higher levels of intelligence because they
learn quickly, then they get bored easily,
~ they and then they're they want
something new.
They want they want to
Mm-hmm.
learn something new. And so that's that's
fabulous,
right? But I'm also trying to lay that
over in the business realm.
And wondering what your experience has
been with men and how can they
be able to satisfy this need to learn more
and do more?
And this wiring of pushing and and and
this without burning out,
without how how do they find that balance
when they're in a workplace,
when they're in leadership, when they're
what you know,
they might be the manager, they might be
on a team,
and they're they're smarter possibly than
the average person in the room,
or maybe they're filled with a room.
Full of very smart individuals
Mm-hmm.
and wanting to have that novelty and maybe
t how do they not do that too much?
How do they set that boundary where
they're not going too far with that?
But then also along that same line,
what if they're in position where their
employer,
they're really good at one particular area
and their employer wants them
to stay in that area because they're
fantastic at it and they start getting
burned
out because they're they want something
new.
But they're an expert in that area.
And so it's like how how
Mm-hmm. Sure.
the how the balance is how how how would
that play out?
What's your experience been with men that
you've talked to along these lines?
Well, I'll comment on your first point.
There is I think it's a l it's a little
bit easier in leadership for you
to be able to reflect on this,
but one of the biggest learning lessons
that I've had over time,
I used to be the guy that would be sending
out emails at midnight
or 4 30 in the morning. And I occasionally
do,
not intentionally. It's just I'm catching
up or,
you know, getting up early and things like
that.
And
What most leaders I think don't realize is
that the impact that it
has on the recipient of that email,
right? And this for some,
they're gonna think my boss is emailing me
at midnight and now I need to respond,
right? And things like that. One of the
biggest learning lessons that I had
is I was at an airport one day and I often
just talk to other business travelers.
And I that day I happen to be doing like a
midday flight,
which I almost never do.
usually like a 6 a.m. or a 7 a.m.
flight person. I don't like to fly
anything later than 9 a.m.
It feels like I'm losing time there.
And so I started
Okay.
to chat with him and I said, hey,
I normally do early morning flights.
And he looked at me and he's like,
I never do early morning flights.
I I used to do that when I was younger.
And so we got into a conversation and he
he basically told me that hey look when
you especially as a leader, when your pace
Like your work ethic and your pace becomes
your identity.
The people, especially who follow you,
who work for you, they don't just see the
results,
they see the costs. And so they start to
internalize,
I don't know if I want to do what he does.
I don't
Mm.
know that I want to be sending out emails
at 4 a.m.
I don't know that I want to be jumping on
a plane at 6 a.m.
every Monday. And so that had a a profound
effect on me because I
was realizing that my pace was.
Potentially putting a damper on others,
especially the people who report to me,
and I don't want them to feel that way or
that they have to catch up.
So that's been a huge shift for me.
you know, as in regards to the novelty
piece,
you know, I I do move on from things
pretty quick,
but I I I have seen others that want to
move on from one thing to the next,
but I but I am someone that I can say that
I do complete my work.
do complete my projects and I I'm not I I
guess I I put excellence
and doing things really well over quantity
and you know so I I'm
not someone that wants to move on to the
next job or anything like that.
I I I truly am someone that wants to
master my craft and where whatever
environment
that I'm in it now. But I have seen
several people who want to move
on from one thing to the next.
Yeah. Again, back to balance, you know,
Mm-hmm.
trying
to figure that out. It's it's a it's a
minefield sometimes and it's choices,
choices of how to figure out how to do it
the right way.
Sure.
So we are unfortunately out of time today,
but Dennis, I know that the listeners and
the viewers want to know how to
get a hold of you, how to learn more about
Sure.
you, you know, your book and everything.
And by the way, since I have the book
right here,
I'm gonna show it. Anyone on
on YouTube we'll be able to see this.
I'll do the same. There you go.
I love it.
Thank you.
I love it. so what is there a website that
you would like them to visit?
How how would you like for them to to
access you?
So the best way would be Instagram.
So I it's funny,
before I wrote my book, I'll just say
this.
Before I wrote my book, I was I hadn't
done a Facebook post in seven years.
And so I I naturally don't have like this
large audience.
I was very rarely on social media,
~ just focused on parenting and and work
and and and taking care of myself.
And then I wrote the book and I realized I
gotta market this damn thing.
So I
Ha ha ha.
I I did start an Instagram page and I've
been actually having a lot of
fun with it and you know trying to to keep
it light and and you know.
you know, post some content that's gonna
adhere to many different audiences.
So it's it's keep the edge on Instagram.
So it's keep dot the dot edge on
Instagram.
So that's the best way to find me.
And of course the book is available
exclusively on Amazon.
So yeah, that's the best way to catch me.
Fabulous. Got the word. And that's all
gonna be in the show notes.
So Dennis, I really appreciate you
spending your precious time
and your your knowledge, your wisdom,
your experience, your stories with myself
and and all of my listeners and viewers.
Thank you very, very much.
Yeah, thank you so much for having me and
appreciate your time as well.
Take care.
Now, listeners, viewers, I know you have
heard multiple things today that you're
thinking, I have a friend, I have a family
member,
I have a coworker that needs to hear
exactly what Dennis is saying.
So take this podcast episode, copy and
paste the link,
send it in text, send it in email,
post it on your favorite social media
sites so we can grow
our Phoenix inflame community and let
people know you are not alone.
I hope your day has been great.
I hope the rest of your day is fantastic.
I'm Dana on Phoenix and Flame.